[Applaudissements]
geslin l'amour entre amour et surtoilés
bien dans trop mais tu es le bienvenu et
oui mathieu les smart intérieur cuir
rouge exclusive ça s'achète la demande
de cyril ça se gagne jamais y verraient
délivrer les billets sont nominatifs à g
et surveiller la télé et je batte au bac
qui est là ton futur mari autre fait
comme chez toi
bienvenue dans mon coeur
autre coup c'est le malaise de thomas et
marine s'est invité chez les uns et une
bagarre familiale on dit vaut vous avez
votre place dans cette situation oh non
non non moi je ne veux pas prendre parti
pour son écoute
elle sort un film j'ai un spectacle
bonne soirée non mais ça devient lourd
protéger les artistes vous voulez
demande connecter le monde connaît non
ça va jusqu'où tu vas pas mâché ses mots
c'est las vegas et bekkouche est ce que
je me suis emporté s'attend pas le droit
non là je suis parti à mourir ce même
jour je vais pas tarder à partir de ce
que j'ai une avant-première à bercy où
les gens vont me tende à la fin il doit
y être à 21h tous les mois ma chronique
léché tout je veux partir
[Applaudissements]